sept sketches et parle de viol et là je
m'attendais pas à voir comme ça il est
comme ça il a une cravate et un dahouët
quand il sort dans le monde y met une
cravate un bernard j'essaie d'être
propre effectivement il essayait d'être
propre et où il était secrétaire
nationale des verts il n'est pas
écrivain à succès il n'est pas star de
cinéma et tout donc une ligne cravate
c'est quelque chose d'assez bull vous
voulez rentrer chez moi bien fini ils
veulent enlever la balle et la bac
[Applaudissements]
mettez vous à l'aise carnaval à son gré
des médias vers voilà comme ça vous la
lessive les lycées d'agacer la tête je
vais l'enlever car voilà
à la halle et on travaille on en donne
hélas sandrine accord non les mains au
couvent où l'ordre et de cadeaux la
chevelure lâchée
voilà sans rapporter à vincent lindon
qui vient alors cette journaliste
pendant 11 ans j'ai travaillé à france 3
tf1 puis après il est devenu écrivain
reporter les intéressés à pas mal de
personnages troubles à commencer par
françois mitterrand au pasteur doucé à
carlos à papon au banquier françois lamy
de mitterrand un maître vergès donc vous
aimez les personnages comme ça un petit
peu trouble à kibera au boulot bien
lille qui s'appelle les mystères de long
donc chez flammarion
pourquoi pas de longs pourquoi
s'intéresser à de longs non c'est tout
bête c'est tout simple pourquoi pas de
longs jeudi c'est un des plus grands
acteurs français contrebas bel 20 degrés
moi parce que personnage ambigu complexe
bon qui peut qui peut réclamer l'envoi
de six classiques un dire du guépard qu
avant tout les filles que nous
connaissons et que nous admirons c'est
quand même là des français les plus
connus au monde
c'est aussi l'une des personnalités je
dire les plus populaires et voir
controversé aussi d'autres en france
alors en 98 vous avez vous écrit d'un
synopsis sur une biographie non
autorisée d'un an selon vous la donner
aux éditions grasset que notre ami
beigbeder connaît bien et donc laure
adler qu'elle est liée plus là non à
l'époque laure adler travaillé chez
grasset et donc elle qu'est ce qu'elle
fait elle reçoit votre synopsis pour
elle le donne alain delon oui c'est une
amie effectivement une vraie reine
jamais travaillé dix auparavant chez
plon et qui effectivement on s'est cru
obligé de donner en douce le synopsis à
ce qu'elle avait lu vraiment où est ce
qu'elle a voulu faire plaisir aux
avocats de long enfin bon tout parti de
long qui lui portent plainte et vous
vous portez plainte contre grasse et
parce que finalement ça se fait pas quoi
oui jo tourner en rond là on a rangé
take-two ce canal
les autres mais bon finalement je veux
dire que de l'eau a réagi comme il
réagit habituellement j'ai pas le
premier biographe à qu'il interdit
d'écrire un bouquin il avait déjà fait
dans les années 80 la duo que tout
pataquès qui a eu pour koné c'est moins
la démarche de l'eau qui était quelqu'un
c'est brutal a ses bons et mais la
décision de justice et du comment
surréaliste qui a dit ben voilà tel
écrivain ne peut pas écrire de bouquins
ça va vous intéresser savez c'était
assez curieux ça cas unique dans
l'histoire de livres interdits avant
même d'avoir été écrit je les visite une
jours le livre est le dernier refuge de
la liberté et la même de même ça enfin
vous avez des problèmes avec les marques
on en a parlé mais même ça vous ça vous
était interdite puisque vous ai même pas
pu écrire aux listes puisque déjà le
synopsis était interdit donc voilà on
fait que moi oui ensuite la justice a
débouté de long de tout c'est alors
allez vous devez donner votre projet
aussi à fayard alors fayard c'est pire
que tout ils ont demandé la permission à
diamant la réponse est non non c'est une
chance pas tout à fait sûr j'avais déjà
sorti trois bouquets chez fayard claude
durand est un grand patron il a dit le
projet m'intéresse mais ce serait bien
que de l'on soit d'accord donc il a pris
sa pluie puisqu'il le connaissait lui a
écrit un petit événement l'autre
indifférent now qu'elle n'a pas répondu
du tout voilà et vous l'avez proposé à
flammarion qui à l'époque a dit non et
aujourd'hui les résidences c'est parce
que delon était intervenu
personnellement avait téléphoné au pdg
directrice générale en disant oh je suis
au courant qu'ils approchent des
biographies le concernant vous la
publier je vous fais un procès vous le
perdez bon effectivement ça fait peur
continue que l'effectif des procès
coûterait cher mais flammarion a dit don
d'un premier temps et depuis quelques
semaines un état a dit on va pas se
laisser intimider
on va faire ce qu'aucun avec le jeu
l'est on voit un signal
un contrat avec un faux nom c'était ça
s'appelait les hommes du président aller
chercher de l'eau là dedans mais c'est
noah s'est bien passé alors donc le
synopsis donné à deux ans par laure
adler a été publié à l'époque par
marianne précédé numéro du 17 août
98 et donc on va voir on va comparer un
petit peu si vous voulez bien vert à
violer ce qu'il y avait dans le synopsis
eskeland bouquin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors bernard violet donc on va comparer
un petit peu sur les origines de 2,2
l'on sait à peu près ce que vous aviez
prévu d'écrire donc le père de l'enfant
fabien delon et gérant d'un cinéma à
bourg-la-reine qui s'appelle l'origine à
il quitte la mère edith qui épouse à ce
moment là le charcutier de la grande rue
de bourg la reine
paul boulogne bon jusque là c'est à peu
près ce que vous aviez prévu
alors là où ça commence à diverger entre
le synopsis et le livre c'est aussi ça
la liberté d'expression
c'est au sujet de l'indochine dans le
synopsis vous écrivez que delon est
poursuivi pour vol d'une jeep ça assez
dans le bouquin mais vous dites qu'est
saigon il est l'amant d'un dénommé et
dans le livre vous écrivez qu'évidemment
il vole une jeep il ya plus de trace de
son amant de saigon parce que ça relève
de la vie privée parce que je n'ai pas
pu avoir parce que nous investissons
rassure en fait je n'étais je n'ai pas
pu recouper g il recoupe effectivement
cette information mais j'ai pas pu la
publier je n'ai pas voulu publier parce
que ça relève de la vie privée des uns
des autres et où c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que delon a fasciné les femmes
durant de longues années il fasciné
l'excité de la même façon les hommes
c'est vrai c'est pas un secret bon il
était beau la porte quelques semaines la
nar gauche de l'eau était de vote ont
l'amour n'a rien à voir avec ça bien
alors premier point bon ensuite de long
il rentre à marseille alors dans le
synopsis décrivez qu'alain delon est
arrêté pour avoir acheté un revolver un
trafiquant qui l'a dénoncé et dans les
vous écrivez que via un vol de revolver
dans des circonstances jamais bien
éclairci dans les deux cas il fait 45
jours de prison
là aussi vous êtes un petit peu en
retrait par rapport au synopsis vous
n'avez pas comparer un synopsis sans
barreur ya un mois j'étais un travail de
compilation avec un travail d' enquête
sérieux qu'a durés effectivement dure
depuis deux ans où je là j'ai pu
recouper les informations où j'ai pu
recueillir des témoignages recueillis à
des documents rec estion c'est
de long at il attaqué va-t-il attaquer
est ce que ce livre est peut être saisi
en référé ou pas ça la vraie question
parce que s'il le fait sur un synopsis
il va le faire sur votre livre pour
l'instant depuis une semaine que le
livre sorti lé messager annonce le livre
en même temps c'est dire qu'on ne
souhaitait pas à référé parce qu'il mord
livre est sorti en douce on l'a pris au
hasard en catimini par douches pour les
dents continue alors dans le synopsis
écrivait que romy schneider partage
alain delon avec visconti lentilles
n'existe dans le livre vous écrivez
visconti est impressionné par la beauté
du jeune homme et que remis dément les
relations amoureuses de long avec
visconti c'est tout à fait exact c'est
pas un secret visconti aimer les hommes
il a est amoureux d'alain delon il est
amoureux du photographe or ce qu'il a
vécu pendant pas mal d'années et
beaucoup de cocteau est amoureux de sa
mère je vous dis là bas mais bon je vous
dis je dirais écrivait que romy
schneider doit partager deux longs avec
visconti est dans les normes
autre chose écrivait que vit ce qu'on
avait impressionné par la beauté du
jeune homme les corollaires dément les
relations non mais sur mon boulot c'est
un document de travail destiné à une
amie bon contre les livres s'appelait
secret d'alcôve donc là je m'étais un
peu lâché dans ce synopsis pensant lui
faire plaisir je vais rajouter quelques
louches
bon voilà c'est tout sachant que c'est
peu dire des choses
en privé on peut dire des choses dans
les couloirs de votre studio 1 ils ont
dit les choses
un des histoires de fesses et du coup on
rit et
ce qu'est ce que j'avance qu'est ce que
j'avance à l'italienne sur votre plateau
bon bon sachant que romeyer est voit
qu'effectivement donc la fascination
quand ses mémoires comme un non mais
c'est comment vous avez su que romy
schneider évoqué telle ou telle chose
écrit maintenant quoi dans son journal
qui est publié chez michel lafon je
crois et or il existe alors voilà en
fait vous inventez pas grand chose alors
il faut lire le journal de romy
schneider et puis en fait c'est toujours
vous avez raison vous j'en suis content
de ma vie personnelle dallas doublons
qu'on n'apprend pas grand chose j'ai
pris le 20 mai ou telle déclaration
nadolo intéressés d'apprendre des choses
qui est à se lancer sur quelques
intentions
durant cette récession
[Applaudissements]
si bernard histoires de fesses quand
même son cadet avec toutes les histoires
de fesses qui vous intéresse bon qui est
pour qu'on dévoile la vie privée des
stars ensemble oui
et maintenant c'est et c'est vous qui la
protéger c'est le monde à l'envers
c'est curieux je suis continuer parce
qu'il ya d'autres exemples par exemple
dans le synopsis écrivait qu alain delon
et l'amant de romy schneider satiété
dans le synopsis publié par marianne
qu'alain delon et l'amande de romy
schneider plus de magna de magda pardon
schneider +2 georges boom qui était son
agent
1 et le soir quand il rentrait alain
quand il rentrait dans l'appartement de
george bush baptisé l'attendent lui
quand il rentrait remis magda sa mère et
georges baume chacun espérant la voir
pour lui pour la nuit
ça c'était dans le synopsis vie privée
vive et dans le livre vous écrivez
en fait la rencontre de alain delon et
georges beau mais vous dites il a été
été un choc pour georges baume la beauté
éblouissante d'alain tout habillé de
cuir noir etc ont remis qui est logé
chez genre je vous mets ça de poser et
il va arriver à paris vous vous dites
vous parce que vous utilisez beaucoup la
question vous êtes très mal un bolide
prévient-il la naïve remis des ragots
qui risque de courir
que signifie cette étrange trio
entendons bien entente on bientôt dans
certaines réactions 6 hiromi heures pour
reprendre un les sources de romy
schneider effectivement elle se pose
également toutes ces questions elle y
répond dans son journal
effectivement on se poser la question à
l'époque elle a cru bon il répondait lui
raison je crois mais on n'a pas là
je veux dire il fait un synopsis des
hard et je me fais jeter à la gueule et
maintenant il revient avec un bouquin il
nous dit bon invectives mans vous savez
thierry vous chercher la petite bête
lorsque vous faites très bien c'est la
technique de la question c'est ce que je
disais que signifie cette étrange trio
ça il ya un point d'interrogation donc
ya pas d'affirmations vous en sortez
très très bien bien alors sur la sphère
marco vicaut revanche là vous êtes
raccord avec le synopsis je dois vous le
dire
c'est à dire que vous êtes gentil ce ne
sont pas gentils j'ai bon c'était des
clins d'oeil si j'ose dire à laure adler
qui n'est pas fait à butiner d'être
publié synopsis les jamais sachant qu
effectivement ça s'était extrait aussi
d'un contexte de 18 pages du synopsis ou
non citées ces lignes je veux dire tout
ça c'était ceci est intégré dans nos
travers et vous allez faire vendre
beaucoup d'exemplaires du marianne du 17
août
je peux vous dire qu'ils ont tout vendu
à la ferme a recueilli que la bon vous
êtes assez en relation avec le synopsis
des relations de long avec le milieu
vous maintenez que marco vic qu'il est
donc un truand yougoslave était l'amant
de nathalie delon qui était une des
femmes reste inconnu nathalie
lavez lavez rallye remis sur le procès
verbal
et puis
jeudi elle avait dit d'ailleurs à ce
moment vous marrez pas la marlin parce
qu'il fait là il prépare un livre sur
vincent lindon et
bizarre j'ai sollicité d'ailleurs
vincent lindon par foyer et qui était le
seul comédien qui ne m'a pas répondu
marco bernard amende nathalie delon
retrouvé mort bon ça vous est raccord
avec le synopsis il avait dit à dire
quelque temps auparavant mais qui touche
à ma femme il est mort je n'ai pas
compris le mec qui touche à ma famille
il est mort il avait dit de l'an
qu'est-ce que t'en vas jetons plus joli
que sort ils en ont l'habitude celui qui
me vole je lui pardonne celui qui vole
ma femme
le tu sais tu apprends verbe yougoslave
pas par rapport à la faire attention
sachant qu'un je ne savais plus si
c'était nathalie mireille ou quelles
femmes qui sont attendus de londres
semblaient d'ailleurs prêts portrait
alain delon c'est très étonnant on
dirait juste un agresseur ou des frères
et soeurs et j'étais un grand homme nous
avait il avait des chemises en crédits
bancaires charrel pareil on a eu envie
tello de même lorsque nathalie ils ont
colonisé dénoncé des versets sataniques
doc a quitté à la veut dire de loi
énormément souffert et je pense que cela
ait été sincère bien alors y habitent de
l'amitié d'alain delon avec le pen ça ça
n'a pas changé non plus les enfants ça
y'a pas de changement non plus vg tout
et j'ai eu mes enfants y les problèmes
avec anthony les problèmes relation père
fils et l'attaqué au tribunal quand il
avait lancé une marque de fringues qui
s'appelait à d anthony delon ça
ressemble et alain delon donc il attaqué
son propre fils à l'ua au tribunal
ça lui fait néanmoins mal imprimés sur
ce match et jean pierre foucault je sais
je suis sont réconciliés ils se sont
réconciliés la mêlée
non alors il ya un outil dont vous
parlez qui est harry enfin un run by
tahri qui est le fils de la chanteuse
underground nico qui ait jamais été
reconnue par de longues qui a été levée
par la mer de long un jour de l'on
appelle sa propre mère est dit en lisant
faut choisir maintenant si tu continues
à élever mon fils on se parle plus assez
pour que ça c'est déjà pas mal mais rien
dire a élevé le fait c'est l'adopter
donner son nom ouais c'est pas rien
ouais
et là je crois que les problèmes avec la
mer ouais moi avec de longs les lignes
oui je vérifie sa mère cccc mêler de sa
vie privée
dire qu'il reconnaît ce qui ne laisse
pas de gamins ça la regarde et pas un de
s'impliquer dans les projets de son
dallas j'ai récupéré ses fils et non
seulement le récupérer il ya plus d'une
décennie
bref c'est un peu surréaliste et le
colonel bibliothèque avec des chants sur
l'autre pleure quand on revoit le film
effectivement allemande il très très
beau film
nicolas akon où on voit harry qui écrit
et subit la rue jean blanc sera tenté
tous enfin bon juste avait donné raison
à de loin je dirais oui maintenant il a
un peu dans la dèche non c'est terrible
moi lorsque je rencontre et donc on
avait 99 il vit dans un squat de 10,2 me
rendis cement
bon c'est pas c'est un secret de dire
que bon je l'invité à déjeuner discute
qui elle a passé l'après-midi ensemble
et en partant il m'a demandé d'un franc
pour rentrer chez lui quoi pour se payer
mais trop pathétique bien et puis alors
il répond par avance parce qu'il sait
tout c'est alain delon donc il répond
dans le journal de karl zéro qui
s'appelle le vrai journal donc vous
l'avez lu ça je crois parce que 15 0
devait publier des bonnes feuilles du
livre et puis qui s'est dégonflé parce
qu'il a eu peur de delon est ce qu'ils
se connaissent ils ont tourné ensemble
dans le film est en photo avec delon
karl zéro j'étais l'ami d'alain delon
car il n'a pas trahi il m'a pas trahi il
a pas annoncé la sortie du bouquin
ouais donc mais il voulait remettre dans
le court terme ou alain delon rainbow et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus